[Music]
hey you guys got a second can you talk
to you about something whatever it is
can wait Rosie you're gonna want to see
this question what is the number one
problem with the coronavirus Mass deaf
economic collapse the way the disease is
exposed to systemic Justice at the core
of American life well yes obviously
those but after that it's how to
high-five your friends while staying six
feet apart right now the world can stop
their worrying because we have created
the covid 5. with this machine you can
execute any high five your heart desires
there's the classic slit me some skin
sprinkle me sprinkle me sprinkle
sprinkle me the Vulcan scissor
that's a bad one yeah and of course the
Need for Speed
wow that was impressively stupid I know
right so what was it you wanted to tell
me just wanted to say goodbye I turned
in my resignation I quit the force
dude that was by far the best five
you're you're quitting hey everybody I
got your text it's a big emergency we
need to talk about Captain Holt's love
life come on you miss getting dragged
into your co-worker's personal lives
admit it it's true I have what's going
on Captain Holt is in pain and we need
to help him get back together with Kevin
no we don't Holt is a very private
person we shouldn't get involved okay
you guys probably don't know this but my
parents got divorced when I was a kid
and it really messed me up yeah what do
I talk about it a lot it doesn't matter
the point is we can't let that happen to
Daddy Holton daddy Kevin so we're just
dispensing with subtext now yes this
workplace is my family was that not
clear Holt is my dad you're my immune
older sister Amy's my mom what what what
did I say you said Amy is my mom nobody
said anything we don't have time for
this Amy now who's gonna help me Parent
Trap Holton Kevin
seriously nobody's on board with my
scheme is because I called it a scheme I
can say something different nobody's on
board with my strategy
Look Hope just needs us to be there for
him help him take his mind off of Kevin
he's always inviting us to his lake
house to go bird watching but we never
do it because it's you know heard
watching we could finally go he would
love that wow stabbed in the back by my
own mom what wife I said wife why do you
keep not hearing me whatever let's just
do Terry's plan
for most people a burrito is a delicious
meal wrapped in a tortilla but for one
NYPD officer it turned out to be a mouse
wrapped in a nightmare so I ordered a
grande steak I get back to my car take a
big bite and crunch that's when I see it
a dead mouse a dead mouse that Franco
Sullivan the president of the
patrolman's union says was put there on
purpose this was an act of political
violence organized by a group of radical
anti-cop antifa anarchists working out
of the burrito here this is Bogus the
officer called in a to-go order under
the name Tom the restaurant had no idea
he was a cop when they made the food or
packed the bag so clearly he wasn't
targeted for being a police officer I've
always wanted to try mouse meat I hear
it's really tasty from who the union
made it up as a power move Sullivan
wants me to issue a statement of public
support for the officer to give them all
extra Hazard pay and to wear this never
forget burrito ribbon weird it's the
exact same color as my colorblind
awareness ribbon no it isn't I won't
give in to any of their demands the
union is powerful but I'm sure that most
of our uniformed officers understand
this incident is nonsense it is as
Peralta would say no big whoop I
appreciate the shout out sir but I
actually don't pronounce the h in whoop
sir all the uniformed officers just left
they're staging a walkout well
it seems I was wrong so hoop is Big
after all
it is again no there's there's no h in
what it's silent whoop whoop whoop am I
crazy how do you say it take whoop okay
listen up everyone we had a murder this
morning the Vic was found at 8 45 by a
dog walker who led herself into his
apartment oh my God it's Franzia this is
the work of Johnny Franzia my white
whale he's finally resurfaced look at
this again yes this again Johnny Franzia
has been on a murder spree for the past
10 years and every time he kills someone
he taunts me look there's a deck of
cards you say that whenever there's
cards at a crime scene you know how many
people own cars Jake then explain this
Johnny franzia's catchphrase is deuces
are wild now look around the apartment
two chairs two paintings two pillows
there are three lamps you think Frenzy
it gives a damn about lamps you sound so
dumb right now this is why you don't
have an arch nemesis Terry because you
focus on the wrong details maybe I don't
have an arch nemesis because I saw all
my crimes
that's a productive thing to say to me
parenting is exhausting you're tired
because you were up until five in the
morning playing a game on your phone
it's not a game it's a realistic pizza
parlor simulator it's very different
there's no winning and why do you play
to earn Pizza points to get better
toppings what's up Peralta hey Trudy
Judy and dog Judy what's going on are
you puppy sitting for Doug well I was
but I need you to take them for me
because I'm going on a little vacay and
let's just say there's gonna be some
activities that aren't suitable for a
little dog
like parasailing not you were building
to something much more sexual nope just
really pumped for parasailing also
there's gonna be a lot of but the dog's
okay with that hair oh as much as we
would love to take care of this
extremely unneutered animal we can't
because I'm too allergic wait why isn't
Doug Judy taking care of dog Judy is he
out of town or something oh no you
didn't hear Doug got arrested he's going
to prison wait what Doug got arrested
he's going to prison no I heard you I
was just processing
um you want to hug a dog oh my God it's
like a third of him imagine everyone a
bomb was just found on a bus in downtown
Brooklyn oh my God a bomb on a bus it's
a speed I get to work a speed that
sentence is nonsensical one can work
with speed but one certainly cannot work
us speed is a movie I won't let you ruin
this well we've never seen speed sir
Keanu Reeves Sandy Bullock Jeff Daniels
at the height of his sexual Powers you
can please just focus the bomb can go
off at any moment actually it can it's
already been defused wow well there's
still a bomber on the loose you can't
ruin this all right tell me about the
bus was it headed to the courthouse it
wasn't an MTA bus it was that a
marvelous Mrs maisel tour bus no you're
not ruining this has anyone heard from
the bomber has he made any demands oh
special agent fine gold FBI this is our
case you're not a part of it oh man you
ruined it
good morning cousin Tommy I love you
good morning cousin Mel I love you
good morning cousin Sam I love you
good morning cousin Tommy I love you
Becca I love you good good morning
cousin Sam I love you
good morning Pappy Boyle I love you good
morning Becca I love you
oh extra long hug well I've gotten to
you this morning Pappy
[Music]
lastly on a personal note as many of you
know Kevin and I have recently
reconciled noise somebody's getting some
it's true I am now when we originally we
had we didn't know how long gay marriage
would be legal so we had somewhat rushed
ceremony do you Kevin yes and do you yes
yes we do we're married Kevin has always
regretted it so we're having a vowel
renewal ceremony this time we're pulling
out all the stops it will be a truly
extravagant Affair oh how extravagant
are we talking champagne pyramid
destination wedding celebrity officiant
we got the solid Forks can you believe
in a second Fork who do we think we are
Oh no you're shocked at how garish it is
now I don't even want to tell you the
other surprise I have in store for Kevin
wait let me guess you're getting bread
plates don't be absurd we're not crazy
no the big surprise is
I'm retiring from the NYPD wait what
why did you lead with the salad
[Music]
Terry loves waking up Terry good morning
honey oh what the hell are you doing
it's holding Amy's last days we're
having a final heist it's Heist day
couldn't you just send an email nope
this is the only way I have to go alert
the others
it's ice day Rosa sorry about your milk
gotta go
it's I stay Charles where's Nikola she's
crying in the closet gotta go
babe what are you doing
I was hiding so I could surprise you but
if you're here then who's in our shower
it's me Captain Holt it's Heist JJ oh
[Music]